Howdy Folks my throat is feeling better
enough to record a YouTube video so here
I am I plan to upload weekly for the
next month to clear out the backlog of
videos I've been working on so hopefully
that can fill the deep hole in your
heart that I'm all but certain my
absence has rought I also have a big
video about manabases coming up later
this month and with that in mind I
figure I may as well run back through a
subject that is near and dear to my
heart land counts now I did talk about
this a bit in my lands video almost a
year ago but there was a bunch of other
stuff in that video and my thinking has
developed a bit since then so I figure
this video can serve as a more targeted
guide the question I'll be looking to
help you answer in this video is how
many lands should my deck have in it and
perhaps more specifically should my deck
have more lands in it to help me out
with answering this question I'll be
using a deck I built in March of last
year my R battle cruiser deck you can
watch the video about it if you want but
the relevant information for this video
is that it is a deck with a manad dor
Commander a pile of four man ramp spells
and a bunch of six and seven drops
filling out the rest of the deck
resulting in this deranged Mana curve it
also runs 41 lands a bunch of people
have made decks riffing off of this deck
which is super cool I always love to see
my decks being an inspiration for people
what I've also noticed though is that a
common first change for people is
cutting three to four lands from the
deck I guess people must assume that I
pulled the number 41 out of a hat or
maybe that's just my personal preference
I know I've frequently seen land counts
referenced online as an across theboard
preference of sorts for people like
you'll see people say that they prefer
35 lands or 36 lands or that they're a
38 land sort of person and other such
statements I suppose maybe people
consider setting the land count of a
deck they're adapting to their preferred
number as a part of putting their own
spin on it maybe I've also seen people
react with shock or skepticism when I
mentioned that one of my decks has a
land count in the 40s so maybe people
just aren't sold on account that high
regardless I want to discuss the
different factors that should influence
land count discussing how each of them
applied to this deck as an example and
at the end of that process maybe it'll
be a bit more clear why I went with the
number I went with and you might have a
bit more insight on how many lands might
be right for your deck based on its
particular attributes for starters let's
talk about Mana curve Mana curve refers
to the Mana costs of the different cards
in a deck and on the most basic level
the average Mana cost of a deck is an
indicator of how much Mana that deck
needs to do what it wants to do as a
general pattern lower curved decks will
want less Mana than higher curved decks
and will thus also want a lower land
count than higher curved decks however
in the context of Commander this is more
of a correlation than it is a rule and
there are two main factors that
contribute to this correlation one of
these factors is how quickly a deck is
looking to win the game with lower
curved decks typically winning earlier
than higher curved decks power level and
how proactive a deck is will both affect
how quickly a deck looks to be closing
out games but regardless this land Count
versus wind speed pattern tends to be a
reasonably consistent one to see but
simply you don't need to play a land on
turn seven if there is no turn seven
another way that Mana curve can
influence the number of lands a deck
wants is in terms of how accessible the
deck's ways to dig for more lands are a
deck with lots of lowcost draw and
filtering can afford to run a lower land
count as long as it can find the colors
to cast those digging cards whereas
Decks that feature draw and filtering
that cost four or more Mana will want to
run a higher count in order to
consistently get enough Mana to pay for
that draw or filtering or at least
supplement with ramp likewise decks
whose source of dig is more complex such
as a deck that needs both a g Uprising
and some big creatures to trigger it
will want to be careful to run enough
lands to avoid getting stalled out on
Mana before getting the chance to
fulfill the condition that will draw
them into more most of my reasoning so
far has been in terms of how low a land
count a deck can afford to run but it's
also useful to think about the question
of Mana curve in terms of how high a
count a deck could afford to run more
complex or Mana expensive forms of draw
also typically draw more cards and if a
deck has a lot of heavy duty draw such
as a green deck running a number of
cards that draw cards equal to a
creature's power it can be possible to
run a quite High land count without
really feeling negative impacts from it
what happens if you draw 10 cards and
then end the turn with a hand containing
six lands and eight non-land cards you
discard four or five lands that's what
when a deck can readily access powerful
draw that is a bit Mana expensive
running a higher land count is often an
allaround win either you haven't gotten
enough Mana to play the draw yet in
which case a high land count helps you
have a higher chance of getting there or
you have played the draw in which case
you're turning through enough cards to
render that slightly increased land
density negligible what this relates to
really is how good a deck is at spending
its Mana let's think about what we're
worried about when adding more lands to
a deck it's flooding right we're worried
that we'll draw a bunch of lands and
instead of having cool impactful place
to make will be stuck sitting around
with a handful of lands this is a valid
concern and one way to mitigate it is to
run fewer lands but another way is to
make sure that your deck is consistently
able to turn through excesses of Mana
having a higher curve alone will provide
some insulation against getting flooded
since playing a six drop is twice as
card efficient as playing two three
drops this doesn't necessarily mean that
you should pump up your curve to avoid
getting flooded but it does mean that
drawing a lot of lands will be more
problematic for some decks than other
other S as far as tools to reduce
flooding go the sort of big draw I
mentioned earlier is a fantastic way to
improve aex ability to spend mana and
there are a few different options here
decks can run a lot of it decks can run
less of it and run filtering or tutors
to find their way to it and decks can
also just put it in the command Zone
there are also other ways to improve
ability to spend Mana mdfc can be nice
non-land plays if a land isn't needed
and there are also impactful Mana syncs
like X cost and multi-use activated
abilities
utility lands can be another great way
to avoid running out of gas as long as
their abilities are relevant to a deck's
goals so to Pivot over to our example
for this video how does my rata deck do
on these criteria that I've mentioned in
terms of Mana curve it has a
horrendously High average nonland card
cost of 5.33 and nothing below four Mana
in the 99 its cheapest ways to dig for
additional Mana are some draw effects at
four Mana that require additional game
actions to actually begin drawing and I
guess some Cascade cards on five
you could say that the deck's ramp helps
it out in terms of getting lands but
this deck would much rather ramp and hit
its land drops each land is effectively
worth two Mana meaning that every land
drop that this deck needs to ramp out
rather than playing normally Bears an
expensive opportunity cost I bumped the
land count from 40 up to 41 specifically
because I had too many games where I was
having precisely this experience
effectively paying Mana for land drops
that I could be making for free normally
okay so hi curved and a high threshold
to dig for more lands these features
tell me that a low land count would be
tricky to pull off with this deck but
what about its ability to spend Mana in
effective ways for one the high curve
alone gives the deck a nice boost in
maintaining cards in hand it just can't
play cards very fast early in the game
so its hand size stays big for a while
into the game even as it's spending
similar amounts of Mana per turn as the
rest of the table and sometimes more in
addition though the number of draw
spells in the deck isn't wildly high
like 9 or 10 if I'm being generous about
what I consider draw the deck sees a ton
of cards due to the amount of cascade in
it and the fact that several of the draw
spells cost four Mana means that they
pop up reasonably often due to the
nature of the mechanic finally I play a
handful of Mana syncs such as
captivating crew for the situations when
the deck has an absurd amount of Mana
but is low on places to put it and I
also have a panglacial worm for when I
top deck a ramp spell and would quite
like a worm to go along with it with all
of these tools for spending Mana I
rarely feel flooded with this deck even
though the deck runs 41 lands so that
covers the biggest factors that
influence the deck's land count but
let's talk about a handful of others
that can come into play in certain decks
for one the power of Mulligans you can
watch my Mulligan video if you want a
full rundown of this topic but the basic
gist goes something like this depending
on how they're built decks will use
their Mulligans to find some things more
than others some decks will be
prioritizing having a piece of ramp in
their starting hand some will prioritize
a Synergy piece to go with their
Commander some will prioritize a lowcost
creature and some will prioritize having
three or more lands in a probabilistic
sense this is kind of a zero sum
activity you can only use your Mulligans
to hunt for so many things and if you
stretch yourself thin on this front you
might find yourself dropping down to
Five Card hands more often than you'd
like what's good keep in mind then is
that running a land count closer to your
ideal land proportion in your opening
hand gives you more wiggle room to use
your Mulligans to hunt for non land
cards and 42 is the number of lands in a
deck that offers the highest chance for
a three land hand my R deck wants a
piece of ramp every game without
exception a fairly stringent goal for
non-land cards so running a land count
close to this three land proportion
means more three to four land hands and
more ability to aggressively Mulligan
for ramp your deck may be more flexible
in what non-land cards it wants in its
starting hand in which case a lower land
density and a focus on mulliganing for
lands may be a more worthwhile plan but
it's good to consider the trade-offs
regardless another reason somebody might
want to run a higher land count is that
it can allow a deck to have extra lands
in hand more of the time an obvious
application of this is extra land play
cards these are often some of the most
efficient ramp spells out there but
being able to take full advantage of
them requires running a land count high
enough to have extra lands in hand a
less obvious application is that a
higher land count gives a player greater
control on the timing of when certain
lands are played a 32 land deck will
often need to play a Booka bog on curve
in order to not miss a land drop and
this may end up greatly reducing the
effectiveness of the cards ETB the same
goes for Mystic Sanctuary Mortuary Meer
and Talon Gates of Madara getting
substantial utility out of these lands
without missing a land drop gets easier
the more lands a deck runs finally let's
talk about one reason a deck might want
fewer lands some decks care about what's
on top of their deck more than others an
attribute that I like to call the krip
coefficient an example of a deck with a
high krip coefficient would be a
conventional build of a commander such
as joira with light Captain most joira
decks run lots of lowcost artifacts
often alongside cost reducers and then
seek to cast a ton of artifact spells in
a single turn this is a play style that
draws lots of cards one at a time and
wants drawn cards to be either an
artifact or an artifact payoff card and
as a result these checks will generally
want to run as few lands as they can get
away with storm decks as many Dr R decks
might be considered care more about the
top of their Library than just about any
other type of deck and will thus usually
try to run a very low land count a lot
of enchantress and spellslinger decks
will also rank highly on the C trip
coefficient wanting to run as many of
their respective card types as possible
even my shirom slide deck could fit into
this mold to some extent with its
relationship with cycling cards though
the existence of cycling lands and land
cycling cards makes its relationship
with lands quite different than these
other decks the biggest Factor here is
that these are high velocity decks Decks
that churn through cards at a fast rate
and also Decks that run lots of lowcost
cards on the other end of things you've
got decks with larger scale draw
particularly ones that have lots of high
cost cards myata deck is more on this
end of things it runs a couple cards
that draw cards one at a time like Beast
Whisperer and soul of the Harvest but
outside of top deck situations with
these in play it doesn't care too much
about what percentage of lands it draws
so that's how I came to the land count
in this particular deck very high
average Mana cost high threshold to
access draw strong ability to spend mana
and maintain cards in hand and a need to
Mulligan aggressively for ramp rather
than for lands you can follow a process
for this like I did in this video and
I'm showing a checklist on screen right
now that you can screenshot if you like
though this is a rather crude summary
that shouldn't be treated as gospel for
every deck I should also note that
though I position 35 to 37 as a moderate
count with the number of mdfc and
utility lands that we have these days
I'd guess that the median casual EDH
Tech would actually be best served by a
land count of somewhere around 38 you
can even use a formula like that
suggested by Frank Carson if you really
want to be handed an exact number
however both that and the guidelines
I've suggested can only give an initial
estimate and after that it's a matter of
testing when playing a deck try to keep
track how often are you finding yourself
wishing you had a land to play and how
often are you finding yourself wishing
you had a non-land card to play
importantly pay attention to the Lesser
cases of these not just the mega floods
and the mega screws I've seen players
consistently Miss land drops over the
course of several games before hitting a
one in 20 game flood and taking it as a
cue to cut lands if both land shortages
and non-land shortages are happening is
it possible to inject some additional
ways to keep cards in hand into the deck
rather than cutting lands cut out dead
weight cards that aren't improving your
deck's ability to maintain a fluid game
plan to give you more space to work with
or replace some combination of ramp draw
and removal with versions that are more
con concentrated if you can afford to
without making your deck too clunky
adding an mdfc or utility land can also
be a great way to improve the feel of
your deck's card Mana balance to allow
the deck to hit the same number of land
drops but have more ways to spend Mana
or give an additional land drop while
maintaining a slot as a way to spend
Mana depending on what's being cut
modern Horizon 3 had both a lot of great
mdfc and a cycle of pretty lovely
utility lands and in the post mh3
landscape I truly don't understand
people who are Clinging On to load of
mid-30s land counts for their
conventionally curved mid-range EDH
decks add lands they let you cast spells
there's also the question of how to
navigate colors in your lands but that's
a question for another day thanks for
watching and thanks to architect for
supporting the channel remember how I
mentioned how land counts affect
Mulligans with architect there's a
hypergeometric calculator a short squirr
away that gives you an immediate sense
of How likely you are to draw various
numbers of different card types pretty
dang cool if you ask me I'd also like to
to thank my lovely patrons who are on
screen now I just opened up submissions
for my deck review for this month and if
you want a chance to get your deck
reviewed by me you can sign up for my
patreon today for three bucks a month
all right bye